- After you.
- No no no no, after you.
- Alright.
(mellow music)
Hey.
- Hi.
- No one cares about news,
news is dead, who cares?
- That's so good.
- I used to want to be a
children's book illustrator.
- You should!
- What did you wanna
be when you were a kid?
- A ninja.
- That's racist.
(laughs)
So what are you up to tonight?
- I'm just gonna make some pasta.
- Oh you make your pasta.
- Yeah.
- Are you good at cooking?
Do you like cooking?
- I dabble.
- Okay, I hate cooking.
- You hate cooking?
♫ Not a cloud in my sight.
- Hey.
- Don't, you'll mess up my makeup.
- What do you want for dinner?
- I'm going out.
Don't wait up for me.
- I didn't think you were gonna show up.
Damn, you smell so good right now.
- Not in public.
(gentle music)
(mellow music)
(moaning)
- What the fuck.
- Hey.
Where have you been?
- I was out having drinks with Paul.
- Why do you smell like mangoes?
- I had one of those
tropical drinks, actually.
You know, like the umbrellas.
(gentle music)
- Have a nice day.
- You too.